- Garfield!
- [yelps]
- A supernatural presence
is close at hand.
I can feel it.
Set the bait, boys,
set the bait.
Here is paté for the ghost-dog,
here is a wire hanger
for the ghost-baby.
Trio of home-baked macarons
for...
[together]
Sticky Jonathan.
- But Mr. Peepers,
that's my best friend.
- Other people will die.
You'll make friends
with their ghosts.
- Mr. Peepers,
how do you know so much
about ghosts?
[mystical woodwind music]
- Garfield...
♪ ♪
I've never told anybody
this story before,
but my
great-great-great-grandpappy...
was a ghost.
- [yelps]
- Yes, Garfield,
I have ghost blood
coursing through me.
It is my family's eternal shame.
- Is that why they call
you Spiritwalker?
- What?
Oh, no, no.
Don't be ridiculous.
They call me Spiritwalker
because I walk
with such great enthusiasm.
Observe.
[glamorous music]
- Oh!
Oh, Mr. Peepers!
Mister--oh!
Look out!
Mr. Peepers, look at you go!
[laughing delightedly]
Oh, my goodness.